they exist outside of the grid invisible
and untouchable and when someone tries
to catch them they do what they do best
run
Mirror's Edge catalyst is the
reimagining of the 2008 cult classic
Mirror's Edge players must rely on speed
stealth and quick reflexes to traverse
the city of glass in ways such a normal
populace can't on rooftops three
maintenance tunnels and out of sight of
the ever-watchful through percent you
have 5 seconds to comply if combat is
necessary players can use martial arts
in advanced technology to take down
their phone
it's the runner way don't get lost as
the player you take on the role of faith
Connors our runner in the city of glass
your job is simple deliver the package
avoid Krueger sack don't fall
Faith's life is the runners after seeing
her family slaughtered in the November
riots she found herself in the care of
Noah Kai he trained faith to be the
bathroom and she never looked back what
he gonna do next
but with faith discovered something
truly evil she is forced to pick up the
fight against the powers that rule the
city the conglomerate a group of 13
ruling houses fight to maintain their
position in the hierarchy and while this
struggle provides many of the runners
with their jobs it has also caused
tragedy two decades ago a peaceful
November protest quickly turned violent
when a stray bullet caused panic and the
chaos that followed faith lost her
entire family and all she'd ever known
out of the ashes of this conflict closed
3% from his seat of power at Kruger
stuck
Gabriel Krueger has mercilessly hunted
down the resistance and has given orders
to kill runners on sight there is more
to this man than just the desire to rule
grief and rage fuel his turmoil as the
death of a loved one handsome but the
lengths he goes to alleviate his pain
may put the entire city at risk as faith
discovers Mirror's Edge catalyst sets
itself apart with fluid movement and
easy controls player shifts seamlessly
from navigating the world
enemies by using the same momentum that
propels them from a building to knock an
enemy on 20 movement is your defense
momentum is your weapon
the parkour elements that made Mirror's
Edge so awesome are back lined with the
best technology to offer even greater
challenges than ever before the newly
offered mangrove lets players navigate
the city in new and unpredictable ways
also new is the disrupter it allows
players to fry food or sex systems gain
access to restricted areas and destroy
AI when players have mastered the story
mode competitive social play awaits them
race against yourself set beats for
other players to find and conquer or
simply compare your best times against
your friends the city of glass is
changing and you are the catalyst get
ready